(musique mau
- Birmingham, une ville
associée
pour les droits civiques,
oùtititin Luther King a été
emprisonné dans les années 60.hs
se recueillent devant
des monuments en hommage
Pour d'autres, le combat
se poursuit. Merika Coleman
un siège au Sénat de l'Alabama.s
des élections, elle concentre
un référendum pour changer
la Constitution de son État.
"Nous devons enlever
le vocabulaire raciste
de notre Constitution",
explique-t-elle.
Ce que Merika veut surtout,
c'est d'abolir fllllllement
l'esclavage pour tous
les résident
y compris pour les personnes
incarcéréeuiuiui font pour
l'instant figure d'exception.
qu'on a gardé pour maintenir
l'accès à du travail gratuit,
même après l'abolition de
l'esclavage", dé
Un constat que partage
ce jurisquququi voit dans la
modification de la Constitution
un symbole fort.
"Ça révèle une attitude plus
moderne", croit William Ross.
Pan n n Farley étudie
pour devenir barbière.
Dans quelques mois,
qui devrait lui permettrededede,
contrairement à sa réalité
et qu'elle travaillait
sans être rémuné
n,n,n,n,n,n,n,n,n,n,n,n,n,n,n,ne
de 18 années pour meurtre,
n'hésite pas à qualifier
le travail carcéral d'esclavage.
Lisa Bowie abonde dans le même
sens. Son fils est incarcé
depuis 27 ans pour un crime
qu'il a commis lorsqu'il était
remise en liberté sont minimes.
Et pendant qu'il est derrière
les barreaux, Robert gagne
un salaire déris
La question du travail carlll
revient souvent aux États-Unis.
L'été dernier, les détenus qui
en Californie n'étaient payés
quququelques dollars par jour.
On accusait alors
de ces personnes incarcérées
nsnsns un pays où les prisons
sont souvent des entreprises
Le nombre de détenus en Alabama
a explosé dans les quatre
dernières années, depuis que
l'Éles règles pour obtenir
une libération conditionnelle.
En 2018, 54 % des demandes
étaient acceptées, un chiffre
à environ 15 %. Et résultat :leé
aussi pleines et les conditions
(paroles indistinctes)
des vidéos tournées
clandestinement montrent
la gravité de la situation
Violence, insalubrité :
des conditions
le gouvernement fédéral
a qualifiées d'inhumaines.
"J'ai très peur pour mon mari",
confie Diyawn Caldwell,
qui a organisé des grèvelelelels
pour améliorer les conditions.
"On fait de la politique
sur le dos des gens",
dé
une activiste qui milite
pour une réforme en profondeur
du système pénal.
Mais les changements
tardent à venir.
L'Alabama est après tout un État
conservateur, uleseseseseseseset
d'une majorité écrasante,
tant au congrès qu'au Sénat.
Et en période électorale,ololols
qui veulent avoir l'air laxistes
en matière de crime.
"Ils veulent construirecicicicis
de coton", sou V V Veronica,
qui rappelle que les personnes
dans le système carcéral.
Merika sait que ses collègues
républicains n d d d d d d d d i
désengorgeraient les prisons.
Mais sa proposition
d'amendement constitutionnel
a tout
de la législature. Un rare
moment de transpartisanerie
dans une Amérique de plus
en plus polarisée.
"L'Alabama est connu pour deux
et les droits civiques.
On a une chance d'être connu
pour quelque chose d'autre."
C'est fin de semaine de match
à Birmingham. Et ici, lesdededet
bien loin des préoccupations.
Difficile de savoir
si les électeurs voteront g g gr
leur Constitution : abolir
l'esclavage une fois pour toute,
dans une lutte qui